from the beginning we wanted to have a
game that was respectful of players hi
I'm Chris Pruitt
I'm the chief taskmaster and co-founder
of robot invader which is a mobile game
development studio here in Silicon
Valley
our focus is high-end mobile games hi
I'm Casey Richardson and I'm the other
co-founder of robot invader and I'm the
game director of the game wind-up Knight
so the wind-up Knight has been tasked by
a king to rescue the princess from the
Black Knight or the game is divided up
in the books every book has a bunch of
chapters there's twelve chapters in each
book you play through each level and
then once you get one through 12 of the
first book then you can play 1 to 12
book 2 part of the major appealed to us
of Android was that we can develop
pretty much on our own schedule this is
my first time developing for Android but
I was pleasantly surprised to find that
these devices are very very powerful
they can push a lot of Polly's they have
a lot of texture memory so we can
provide a console like game on these
handheld devices when we're ready to
ship we were able to ship on Android
Market very easily
you basically just upload the binary and
hit publish and it's deployed to this
humongous audience of users
one thing that we found is that people
were having troubles with the very first
level and that particularly the fourth
level so we looked at the the data there
and then we decided like to make some
changes in levels so we tweaked the
design of the levels and uploaded that
build and we had a new build with those
fixed levels within 24 hours when we
shift I think the key to being
successful on Android is being able to
run everywhere or at least on is why a
variety of devices as possible so we
made sure that we run well on phones we
run well on tablets we should be able to
scale up to even larger screens you know
if the opportunity presents itself we
have a single binary that we deliver to
all of the devices that are indicated by
our spec we used android markets
filtering capabilities to cut out
devices that we just decided we could
not support we still have phenomenal
user response we're still closing in on
a million users after two weeks we
absolutely made the right choice on
shipping on Android first yeah this is
definitely something we'll do again in
the future
wind-up Knight is robot invaders a first
game but we're gonna have a lot more
after this and we hope that users who
are enjoying wind-up Knight will stick
around and check out our future games on
Android Market
you